the real empowering adventure lies
through responsibility to each other
love and aesthetic anticipation of the
transcendental realm and when these
things are put in place the power of the
naysayers and the frightened and the
materialists and the control freaks and
the business-as-usual crowd will be
broken they cannot maintain no one is in
charge at this moment and this is good
news because it means that for the first
time in a long time these processes are
beginning to unfold themselves without
bearing the imprint of resistance upon
them in the end it's all lost in
radiance the rarefaction and
transformation of the human mind and
body into some kind of eternal golden
vehicle for the groving through and the
discovery of a universe wider grander
deeper than anything that we could
imagine and to preserve its power and
its transformative essence we have to
keep it away from moral prescription
from to clear a definition it is not an
unsolved problem it is a mystery and
closure kills the heart of the mystery
so we have to embrace this uncertainty
not as a problem to become to be
overcome but as an opportunity for
shedding our pasts shedding the monkey
shedding the bad habits of history that
we've accumulated and moving into a
world that is literally beyond our
wildest imaginings it can't be any other
way business as usual as I said is off
the menu and now it's a struggle between
those who would have us lay down quietly
and a kind of anaesthesia anticipating
ruin or those who would have a stand up
and claim our birthright and go forward
into the shamanic domain of the spirit
that exists when the human soul and the
soul of the earth recognize each other
and are united in one and this is coming
and it's possible and it's now and thank
you very much
[Applause]
you